hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren wir haben hier heute Karten vor
uns liegen auf denen Sachen drauf stehen
die wir mit unserer Mimik ohne zu reden
darstellen müssen
das war's
relativ einfach
[Musik]
das irgendwo vorbei gewonnen du bist
richtig gut nein wie war so krass boah
ich bin der heftigste so
ich mache
kotzen
wenn du den krasseste deines Lebens von
dir gibst oh mein Gott
ich schwöre
nachdenken nee nee nee ganz angefangen
[Musik]
wenn Du realisierst dass du besser
singen kannst als du denkst nein Bruder
wenn du Rappen kannst wenn du plötzlich
checkst richtig gut rein kannst wenn du
deine musikalisches gehen entdeckst nein
das war so das zweite Mal gesagt hast
[Musik]
wenn du wenn dir der passende Reim
einfällt nein nicht den ganzen Songtext
richtig rappen kann
[Musik]
was irgendwas aufgemacht was richtig
ja nah dran also
[Musik]
du hast etwas geöffnet
und Bestellung geöffnet
[Musik]
aufmachen
[Applaus]
Essen nee scheiße
[Musik]
gemacht wenn Du realisierst dass du mit
deinem hinsetzen gefurzt hast
wenn du beim Hinsetzen gekackt hast
[Musik]
keine Konserve wenn du die
Ketchupflasche drückst und es aus der
Öffnung rauspupst
wenn du niest
und in deine Hände
schnurzt nein wenn du niest und
dich freust nee ich habe jetzt so
gemacht und dann so ich gucke mich um
wenn du nicht und wartest dass jemand
Gesundheit sagt ja könnte ich gelten
lassen
[Musik]
gemütlich ja ich kann nicht so schwer
das ist ein Kinderspiel setz mich hin
und ich merke das vom Sitznachbarn vor
mir noch der Stuhl aufgewärmt ist
[Musik]
wenn du beim ersten dönerbissen dein
Zahn im Fleisch stecken bleibt schon mal
passiert klar wenn du beim ersten Döner
bisschen merkst ist viel zu heiß ist zu
schaffen
[Musik]
okay du legst dich ins Bett und denkst
irgendein Monsters unterm Bett oh mein
Gott
denkst dass du dein Handy verloren hast
aber direkt neben dir liegt nein du
denkst zu der Portemonnaie verloren hast
aber das direkt neben mir liegt nee also
du suchst irgendwas Taschen also weg ne
das ist neben dir ist
Moment
ich habe etwas verloren die Person neben
dir sagt dann äh du hast es verloren ich
denke du zeigst dahinten in dicker
[Musik]
Ende
du du bist Brillenträger und suchst dann
wenn dir jemand sagt dass du heute dein
Bad Hair Day hast
[Musik]
das war schon
ciao und dann kommt die Person noch mal
zurück und dann
[Musik]
wenn du im Restaurant zu viel Geld
gegeben hast und
Geld ja ja okay also jemand geht und hat
anscheinend Geld vergessen
wenn ein Kollege sagt hey ich Schulte
noch was hat mit Oma zu tun Oma wenn Oma
dir keine Ahnung Kohle zu stecken wenn
du dich verpisst Bruder genau richtig
du willst den Teller sauber machen und
dann fing das den Rest reingegangen
richtig
krass was ein Zufall kann ich kurz ein
Utensilien dazu holen Sprachen lernen
Babbel
[Musik]
wenn dein Hund üben Mundgeruch hat
wenn ein Hund auf meine Terrasse
geschissen hat
wenn dein Hund zwar extrem süß ist aber
auf Lukas Terrasse geschissen hast
[Musik]
okay also offensichtlich hast du einen
Köter und der riecht aus dem Maul best
Jahres aber sein Arschloch ist gut
wenn bei deinem Hund das Maul normal
riecht aber das Arschloch total stinkt
wenn ein Hund aus dem Mund gut riecht
aber
wenn ein Hund aus dem Mund stinkt aber
aus dem Arschloch normal riecht
ja also Antwort wäre wenn der Atem
deines Märchen als seine Pupse okay lass
meine Damen und an der Stelle
wenn ich dieses extrem dumme aber
trotzdem 17,99 € teure Video gefallen
hat und lasst gern einen Daumen hoch
unter dem Video hier da abonniert meinen
Kanal und klickt auf die Glocke weiter
Videos nichts verpassen Pablo hat die
letzten sechs Worte
[Musik]